[Musica]
mio nome
ripiegate le labbra
è tornati al colore di prima
guardo fuori
[Musica]
come fuoco no
ore da qui e ci dobbiamo cantare c'è
un'altra giornata d'amore
preparare
[Musica]
ho visto solo stelle buone sulla pro
pelle
se tornerai domani saprà darti quelle
perse
lascerò che tutto sia sospeso sia quando
ci rivedremo
[Musica]
io amo
il tuo
cuore
mare calmo
non basta una sola notte
per attraversarlo
sono pronta per gli aborti ancora dormi
un respiro mentre il sole svanisce
ombra disegna
il tuo profilo
ho visto solo stelle buone sulla tua
pelle
se tornerai domani saprà darti quelle
perse lascerò che tutto sia sospeso sino
a quando non ci rivedremo
[Musica]
solo stelle buone sulla sua pelle
se tornerai domani saprà darti quelle
perse
[Applauso]
[Musica]
che tutto sia sospeso sino
ci rivedremo
[Musica]
stelle
no
scala
[Musica]
e
sì
[Musica]
grazie
è una bella responsabilità essere qui in
quanto rappresentante di un genere
musicale credo quindi mentre uscivo sul
palco prima mi sono suggerita auto
suggerita di base per caso non va bene
potresti sempre dire comunicazione di
servizio
il rock è morto buongiorno
no no assolutamente non è questa la mia
intenzione ma poteva essere un
escamotage il rock mi sembra chiaro e
altrimenti non saremmo qui è un concetto
e probabilmente esiste da sempre
solo che nei secoli ha cambiato forma
perché non era forse rock bethoven quel
[Musica]
no era un primo rif
se non altro per i capelli di beethoven
poteva essere rock ma poi è arrivata sia
arrivato il suono della chitarra
elettrica quello quello sicuramente ha
incorniciato il rock
ora il rock il nuovo rock sembra essere
il rap perché il rock se è un'intenzione
che ha spesso a che fare con il disagio
oggi evidentemente è espressa meglio da
chi il disagio lo sente più sulla sua
pelle quindi il rap forse veramente il
nuovo rock è un'intenzione quindi
un'intenzione abbiamo detto che è
energia per me io ho usato la parola
mamma perché secondo me il rock la
musica per molti è un po come una madre
una madre che ti invita a essere ciò che
sei
anche se ti senti diverso anzi proprio
perché sei diverso ti invoglia a fare
quello in cui credi come se fosse
l'ultima cosa che fai
in quel momento penso sia una cosa molto
bella e quello che mi ha insegnato il
rock la musica in generale il rock
dicevamo la musica è vibrazione e mi
piace pensare che sia la stessa
vibrazione alla stessa energia la stessa
vertigine che muove i pianeti e poi si
ritrova magari sulle labbra della
persona che ami
[Musica]
parlami del carso
di un codice
stellare che
morire non può
di anime in continuo
mutamento
e abbracci nucleari
belli
sica
dove tu mi stai aspettando adesso
entra un avvertita
sì
e danza e ci porta
sì non ritorna
[Musica]
labbra
l'incanto è lo stesso perché niente
ha cambiato anche se tutto è diverso
[Musica]
canta mi
adesso
di un codice stellare che mentire non fa
cadono nel vuoto in un modo
contro
miliardi di segnare
che accendono
[Musica]
si sa dove tu sai
che poi mi porto
dentro a un aborto
fuggire e danza
e ci porta
al di là del tempo
sino a ritornare
sulle
[Musica]
l'incanto è lo stesso perché
cambiato anche se tutto è
diverso perché niente è cambiato anche
se tutto sembra
[Musica]
[Applauso]
miliardi di segnare
si accendono
sì
sembra una vertigine
[Applauso]
ansa
e ci porta
di là
il tempo un po
sì non ritorna
[Musica]
labbra
l'incanto è lo stesso e tu sei
entro ma per danzar
e ci porta
di là del tempo
dentro una vertigine
[Applauso]
danza e ci porta
quindi la del tempo
[Musica]
grazie
e chiaro che per chi fa questo mestiere
almeno per me è molto più facile mettere
le parole nelle canzoni che parlare
delle canzoni e quindi uno dei motivi
per cui ho cominciato a scrivere canzoni
mi è stato quello di raccontare
l'universo femminile un universo che mi
sembrava poco rappresentato in italia se
non attraverso rari esempi purtroppo è
ancora un po la situazione è quella la
voce femminile in vari campi in italia e
nel resto del mondo è in qualche modo
soffocata o trattenuta e quindi ho
cominciato a scrivere per raccontare la
mia visione del mondo e della
femminilità
un giorno ho avuto una specie di
illuminazione banale banalissima ma che
credo abbia un po a che fare con questa
giornata e ed è quella che al di là di
tutto al di là di quello che ci succede
la prima risorsa per noi stessi siamo
noi stessi quindi ho scritto questa
canzone che si chiama ho sempre me per
il san donà un po come un mantra ho
sempre me ok qualsiasi cosa accada
sempre
[Musica]
sia sicuro
questi dati non segnano mai più di dieci
fanno così per non compromettersi la
stanza in cui vivo è un dado ma non
abbastanza mani per tirarlo lontano
[Musica]
distanze
percorro mai
per una probabile
carenza di ossigeno
devo ancora imparare spirare ma mi va
bene così per cambiare mai
ho sempre
[Musica]
hassan
ehi ehi ehi
[Musica]
grandi
crisi
accendono e buio
però un mentis iscriviti
a farmi subito
o forse meglio
così
io
tutto
potrei avere qualche problema se tu
tornassi davvero
[Musica]
io
[Applauso]
vediamo